في ايام كتيره عدت عليا في الجاني بتاعه
بتاعتي غيرتني وغيرت حاجات كتيره في حياتي
بس انا عايزه احكي لكم على يوم واحد بس
فيهم اليوم ده كان من عشر سنين مثلا كانت
في بدايه الجاني التمرين بتاعتي
وكانت اول مره في حياتي اتضرب في التمرين
اللي هو اخد في وشي واضرب بجد لسه فاكره
اليوم ده كانه امبارح فاكره احساس وهو
بيرضع في وشي ومناخيري ساحت وتوترت وغمضت
عيني وكل حاجه وبعدين فتحت عينيا ولقيت
الكوتش بتاعي واقف بيبص لي بيقول لي هو
انت انت مستنيه ايه بتخشي تلعبي يوميها هو
قال لي انت ضربتي صح فبقول له اه فبيقول
لي طيب هو انت نور انت داخله متوقعه ايه
غير ان انت هتضربي فهو انت هتضربي المره
الجايه لما تيجي تضربي اضحكي وابتسمي
للشخص اللي قدامك وكملي ولا كان اي حاجه
حصلت مهما كان بقى انت اتضربتي كم مره
موجوعه قد ايه نفسك مقطوع انت خلاص مش
قادره
معك وكملي ولا كان اي حاجه حصلت
فاليوم خلص والتمرين خلصت وبعديها رجعت
الترمينا اللي بعدها واللي بعدها واللي
بعدها وانا لقيت نفسي ان انا انا فعلا انا
عماله اضرب عشان وانا داخله بوكسينج
فلكيكه بتضرب بس انا بضحك للشخص اللي
قدامي وببص له وبكمل لحد حتى من قريب كنت
تمرين وبتمرن مع حد واتضربت وبقت خلاص انت
رد فعل ان انا بضحك وببتسم وعيني الولد
مصدوم هو انت بتقولي وانت كويسه انت
بتضربي وبتضحكي ليه يعني مش فاهم
لاحظت ان انا هي اليوم ده هي بس الكلام
اللي هو قاله لي الكود بتاعي زرع فيا بس
فكره اللي هو
عادي ان انت تقعي وتضربي وتتوجعي بس انت
هتقومي ثاني وهتضحكي ولا كان اي حاجه حصلت
بعديها لما الوقت عدى انا لاحظت ان اليول
دي في السبورت بتاعتنا هي جولد هو ما فيش
حاجه اسمها ان انا اضرب واتعصب والوز
كنترول واخش هخسر انا هتضرب وهضحك وهكمل
بعد شويه لما الوقت عدى والسنين عدت وعشر
سنين عدوا لاحظت انه هو اليوم ده لما
اتقال لي الكلام ده مش بس بقت جولدن يقول
في حياتي وما بقاش شخص قدامي هو لابس وانا
لابسه جلفز واحنا داخلين انا عارفه هي بقت
جولد نيول عامه في الحياه
في حياتي وبقت الطريقه اللي انا ببص بها
للدنيا انا عارفه ان هو دلوقتي ما بقاش
شخص هو اللي واقف قدامي هي الحياه واقفه
قدامي كلها على بعضها لابسه بتاعها وانا
لابسه بتاعي وهي يعني بتديني ضرب وانا
عماله اضرب بتوجع وبعيط وبانور وكل حاجه
بس ببص لها واضحك لها واقول لها طيب
وبعدين وبكمل في ناس بتضرب من الحياه
وبتتعصب وبتلوز كنترول وفي الاخر بتلاقي
نفسها وقعت هي هي نفس الفكره في المعيش في
لعيب بيتضرب وبيتكسر وبيعيط وبيخش يبوظ
الدنيا يا اما بيضحك ويكمل
فلما افكر في اليوم ده هو يوم واحد بس قال
لي كلام وكمل معايا بقيت لحد دلوقتي
فلما افكر اصلا مع نفسي هو انا ايه
الستويشن اللي خلتني اوصل لليوم ده اصلا
ايه اللي حصل قبل اليوم ده وصلني ان انا
في تمرين بوكسينج اتضربت والكوتش قال لي
عادي فلاحظت ان هو يوم
ده زيه اللي هو اول يوم تمرين اصلا في
حياتي كلها على بعضها كان عندي عشر سنين
كنت طفله فاسله كده رحت مع اختي الكبيره
كانت رايحه تجرب كيك بوكسينج فقلت لها طب
انا جاي معك كده بدون اي حاجه يعني وانا
اصلا من جوه مرعوبه انا عارفه ان انا
صغيره سنا وحجما بجد حاجه قد كده ورايحه
تتمرن بوكسينج مش اي حاجه يعني مع ناس
اكبر منها سنا وحجما برضو
فاليوم ده لما رحت معها انا فاكراه برضو
كانه امبارح فاكره التسخين فاكره كل حاجه
الكوتشي اصلا مش عارف اسمي عملت حاجه صح
في التمرينه قال لي شاطره يا اختي مريم
اختي اسمها مريم
فانا كنت مرعوبه اليوم ده خلصت التمرينه
طايره من الفرحه بس لسه مرعوبه انا خايفه
عشان هي بالنسبه لي حاجه جديده وانا مش
عارفه انا داخله على ايه دلوقتي
فلما افكر هو اليوم ده رحت التمرين اليوم
اللي بعدها رحت التمرين اللي بعدها واللي
بعدها عدى اسبوع شهر سنين 10 سنين
العشر سنين دول في حاجات في الدنيا بتتحط
لنا
بتخلي بتقعد تزنق الواحد وتخليه هنا في
بابل في مكانه هو سابت ومش بيتحرك الحاجات
دي ممكن تكون الخوف انه في توتر ان حاجه
جديده انا مش عايزه اجربها عشان انا متوتر
او الخوف من الفشل اصلا عامه
او ان انا كلام الناس هيفرق معايا اراء
الناس هتفرق معي ده انا بقابله كتير قوي
في يوم كنت رايحه الشغل وكنت راكبه اوبر
شغلي ساعتها كان في استاد القاهره فالراجل
شاف الاستاد فبيقول ايه ده ده في تمارين
ومش عارفه ايه كده هنا فسالني انت بتتمرني
ايه فبقول له لا انا مدربه مش بمر مش
بتمرن فبص في المرايه كده بيقول لي مدربه
ايه معلش فقلت له مدربه بوكسينج وملاكمه
وكده احنا سايقين والراجل ساب الشارع بقى
وساب عربيات وسايب كل حاجه وبص وراه وبيبص
لي من فوق لتحت وبيقول لي بوكسينج ايه
ملاكمه انت لو انت بتهزري ولا بتعملي ايه
يعني فبقول له والله العظيم بجد ومش عارفه
ايه ففي ناس كتيره ولحد ما وصلنا هو مش
مقتنع برضه
لحد ما شاف المكان وقال لي طب والله ربنا
يوفقك اللي هو يعني كده يعني بس هو في ناس
كثيره هتبقى كلامها مش بيشجع وفي ناس
العادات والتقاليد اللي احنا عايشينها هي
اللي مشياها
كل الحاجات دي الخوف والعادات والتقاليد
او بتاعتنا بنخليها نقف هنا فاليوم ده لما
بس نكسر الخوف حاجه بسيطه جدا
هجيب ايام تانيه وراه وهيحصل حاجات كتيره
احناش عمري متوقعينها عن اول يوم تمرينه
ده لو حد جه قال لي على فكره انت كمان عشر
سنين مش بس هتكوني لسه بتتمرني لا انت
بقيتي كوتش ويوميه ده وناس كتير عايزاكي
تشتغلي معها معهم عمري ما كنت هصدق
فهو الفكره انه اليوم الواحد لو بس زقينا
فيه شويه الحاجه اللي مخليانا هنا ده
حياتنا بعد كده احنا مش عارفين ايه اللي
هتيجي
والايرين ان احنا اليوم ده احنا مش بنبقى
عارفين ان هو هو ده اليوم هو ده اليوم
اللي هيحصل فيه حاجه فهي
انهي انا بزق شويه
الكلياني في حته واحده او كل يوم انا
عايشاه بجد بمعنى ان انا مش يا دوبك اليوم
بتاعي بيعدي عليا زي اليوم اللي قبله زي
اليوم اللي قبله وفجاه اصحى الاقي عندي 70
80 سنه وانا ياه دلوقتي عدى بسرعه قوي طب
انا عملت ايه ولا حاجه ليه عشان الوقت عدى
بسرعه واليوم اليوم عدى علي من غير ما
اعمل اي حاجه ومش اي حاجه بالنسبه للناس
تانيه اي حاجه ان فيديو له مع نفسي لما
ابص على حياتي احس ان انا يا اما انا كنت
وانا حاسه ان انا عشت فعلا حياتي يا اما
انا ما عشتهاش هو في فرق ما بين ليفنج انا
يا اما فعلا عايشه يومي زي اليوم اللي اول
مره اتضربت فيه ده هو فعلا كنت عايشه دي
وما سمعت الكلام بعد كده يا اما هبقى
موجوده في يومي يا دوبك كده اليوم بيعدي
عليا وانا ما عملش حاجه
الفكره انه الايام دي زي اول يوم تمرينه
زي اول يوم لما اتضربت في التمرين هي غيرت
حياتي خدت حياتي كده كانت ماشيه هنا
وجابتها هنا
الكلام اللي الكوشه لي في اليوم ده لما
سمعته والسنين عدت بقى مش حاجه انا ماشيه
فيها في التمرين بس هي بقت حاجه ببص فيها
لحياتي كلها سواء كانت انا عارفه ان انا
هتضرب ان انا لما ناس قريبه مني قوي
اخسارها اتوفوا قلبي اتكسر قمت ورجعت
وعادي او احساس بالفشل ان انا في الجامعه
كان في جول هموت واوصل له قعدت سنه ونص
بوصل له وفشلت فيه
ودي كانت حاجه وجعتني جدا بس عادي لقيت
حاجه ثانيه وشغاله فيها دلوقتي فهو الفكره
انه اليوم اللي هو قال لي ده
زرعت فيها حاجه وكملت او اليوم اول يوم ده
خالص لما رحت التمرينه مع اختي وكسرت بس
حاجز اللي هو انا خايفه متوتره عشان دي
حاجه جديده وانا مش عارفه انا هعمل ايه
جاب اليوم اللي هو بتاع التمرينه واليوم
اللي بعده واليوم اللي بعده ولحد ما عدى
عشر سنين فهو الفكره لو هسيبكم بحاجه
واحده بس النهارده انه دون استميد
ان انتم فعلا تعيشوا يوم واحد لو عشنا يوم
واحد بجد يونافي نو اللي هيجي بعد اليوم
ده انا حياتي الناس اللي عارفاني اصحابي
المدرسه انا كنت واحده شاي جدا وكويت وكنت
خلاص متقبله ده عن نفسي ان انا مكسوفه
وبتاع
فكره ان انا اكمل اتمرن عشر سنين وبعديها
اتحط في بوزيشن ان انا كوتش لا هو انا انا
محتاجه بزعق بقى في التمرين وبقول للناس
تعمل ايه وما تعملش ايه او ان انا قاعده
بتكلم قدامكم عادي جدا كل الحاجات دي بدات
بيوم يوم واحد بس فالفكره انه عيشوا اليوم
بجد عندي شكرا
[تصفيق]